putin
challenges biden to debate after the
president calls him a killer
russian president vladimir putin has
reacted to president joe biden colonel a
killer by challenging biden to take part
in a conversation with him broadcast
live online
putin told the russian state television
reporter i just thought of this now
i want to propose to president biden to
continue our discussion but on the
condition that we do it basically live
as it's called without any delays
and directly in an open direct
discussion it seems to me that would be
interesting for the people of russia
and for the people of united states
biden said he thought putin was a killer
russia recalled its ambassador to the
united states in response to the remark
after issuing his invitation putin said
he did not
he didn't want to delay i don't want to
put this off for long i want to go
this tiger this weekend to relax a
little
so we could do it tomorrow or monday we
are ready
at any time convenient for the american
side
the russian leader also said he wished
biden good health
i would say to him be well i wish him
good health i say that without any irony
without any jokes
adam the truth is there was some irony
and full-on jokes there with putin
um look there's two sides you can kind
of look at this there's the side that
it's like bro what are you doing
like you don't put your out there
and just like reveal your hand
and completely disrespect a world leader
you kind of do it
behind closed doors or you have a little
more diplomacy or
tact um but then there's the other side
that's like
let me just spit the truth and actually
say what the truth is
putin is a killer whether it's on the
micro level or the macro level micro
he's poisoning his
dissidents or pointing people poisoning
to speak out about him he's
former kgb on a macro level he's
invaded other countries um ukraine
um what's the city in ukraine that i'm
thinking of the main area in ukraine
that
they're fighting about help me out here
not kiev
what is it called i don't know the place
in ukraine yeah anyway
he's gone into ukraine he's done um
foreign affairs so the point is which
direction do you want to go do you want
to have diplomacy do you want to have
tact or do you want to tell the truth
and for me biden has to have a balance
of both am i
completely turned off that he would say
something like this
no do i completely agree that he went
this direction
and called out putin on tv not as much
but what i do know
is after the reality show president
donald trump
um a putin biden argument uh debate on
tv would be
reality tv of the highest magnitude
um so we'll see where this goes here but
uh
i um i'm not i'm not sold on either
direction of what biden went here
you know i i think the comment calling
putin a killer just shows how naive
biden is when it comes to to foreign
affairs i mean there was just nothing to
gain with with a
with a comment like that especially
someone like putin who would eat his
lunch
just on every conceivable level you know
the way he's manipulating him now with
the comeback
you don't want to challenge a guy like
that because what if he is a killer what
if he is that crazy
i mean these guys can do hacks at the
drop of a hand he could probably shut
down our
electrical grid if you wanted to i think
a little bit more tact in dealing with
with putin would make a little bit more
sense you know you talk about trump
being the loose cannon but
he didn't really have any outburst like
this
you know most of it was now some people
didn't agree with how he dealt with um
north korea and got a little bit too
cozy with him but
i don't know was he trying to be funny
was he trying to be light was he trying
to be tough
i just didn't think there was anything
to gain by what biden did and i think
it's completely backfired on him
well here's the thing once you become a
president you have to understand one
thing
is john gotti you know who john gotti is
right okay when i interviewed sammy
double garvano i asked him about john
gotti i said
uh oh john another guy
interviewed eli said the fact that john
gotti never killed anybody okay he would
always other people kill
people for him and sami stops me and
interrupts like as if and sammy was like
they're not in the best place with john
gotti but sammy interrupts and just kind
of says
let me tell you something you crossed
john gotti he was capable
he says you know he was capable of doing
anything i don't know if i've ever seen
him kill anybody or not the story about
the dentist i don't know
but you don't want to cross john because
he was capable right
would you consider john gotti a killer
yes
what if he never killed anybody but he
told other people to kill people is he
considered
i think so absolutely so if you tell
somebody else to kill somebody
to defend your your territory would you
be considered a killer
i think so yes then every president is a
killer
okay so if that's the qualification you
just made
you just send troops to syria you're
officially qualified killer
okay if that's your interpretation okay
on where you went
with that trump would be like what do
you think america is so innocent yeah
famous
what i'm trying to say to you is once
you become a president
you have to know you're in the gray area
for four years you're the
commander-in-chief
you're the commander-in-chief so if you
can't sit there and be like oh my gosh
he's such a this
look you you can't you're not an angel
when you become a president
you can't be nobody is not a single one
of our presidents ever has been an angel
some have more more higher morals and
values some less
but the reality is you have to be
willing to call the shots now
was putin one before he became possibly
and that's the reputation
possibly kgb 90 what i'm saying possibly
i don't know i've just read the articles
and it says that he was
okay do i think putin's a killer
i think i've told you this when trump
was president i think putin's the
most brilliant strategist president
powerful person in the world today it's
not the u.s commander-in-chief just so
you know this i put putin at number one
putin is a genius strategist
not more than she right now would he be
no she has more
power putin is a better strategist
putin to me is a street trained
this is the the right guy you want
here's the analogy for putin yeah by the
way crimea was the city in in um
ukraine putin's you know if you're
playing a poker game
and we all have a hand putin's playing
with like a pair of sixes
like uh an offsuit three you know maybe
like a jack and you know like a ten like
there's no hand
yeah but he makes you think he's dealing
with like pocket jacks and pockets
queens or something like that you know
what country has the most nuclear
weapons right now
america okay can you pull up nuclear
bombs real quick
is it russia can you just pull it up to
see what the leaders bulletin says i
like data
that's what i like i like numbers and
data countries
with most there you go click on that
nuclear
click on that put the list
hopefully it's as updated as possible is
there a way to go
leaders bulletin okay russia right there
look look go back up
go back up kai russia 6 375 u.s 5800 i
think you don't want to screw with
russia
okay just so you know china's only got
320. let's face it if russia wanted to
destroy the world and just
leave an island called russia okay he
could do it isn't it
he would be he would be they would be
you know how they say like why is
american military so strong well
you know um a strong military
prevents war prevents warfare exactly
like a strong let me
let me go back to what what biden said
in this interview okay
uh he's talking to stephanopoulos okay
they're going back and forth they're
talking about a bunch of different
things but he says
uh he will pay a price okay we had a
long
talk biden says he and i
when we i know him relatively well and
the conversation started off i said
i know you and you know me if i
establish this accord
uh then be prepared stephanopoulos says
so you know vladimir putin you think
he's a killer
um i do okay you'll see
that putin is going to pay okay this is
what biden says
he continues walk and chew gum at the
same time for places where it's our own
mutual interest to work together
okay so he then says i looked at him in
the
eyes and says i know who you are okay
what do you mean i know who you are
like i know who you are so he's saying
this about putin about a private
conversation that he had with them
um you tell me what other president
prime minister of another country will
trust having a private conversation with
biden moving forward
so one there's recording of you 10 years
ago 15 years ago talking about if you
don't fire that lawyer or that whoever
it is
we're not going to give you the money
that's recorded that's on video
billions of people have seen that you
know which ones i'm talking about where
you know which one i'm talking about
where he's sitting there
so he said it got it biden biden when he
says if you're ukraine
what is this yeah the ukraine where you
say he's going to cut him off if you
don't fire this person
we're going to cut you off you're not
going to get the money right so we know
how
this guy works okay so
in this game not only did putin win
but america lost because officially no
one
in the world is going to trust talking
to biden off camera
the safest place to talk to biden right
now is only one place with cameras on
and guess who's going to do it nobody
the only people that are going to do it
is they'll talk to us in
administration here's the other part say
you're an advisor
you're like uh biden's jim baker james
baker
your bidens whoever just pick one of
them right karl rove your biden's uh
any of those names what do you think
you're telling about you know what i'm
telling biden
bro seriously just kick back you know
what i mean
let her do the talking let somebody else
do the talking dude
nothing and when you're walking up the
stairs we're going to turn off the
camera
when you're going out there having any
kind of questions cut it short
we're going to see you have another
meeting we're going to keep telling
everybody you got a meeting just don't
do any of this publicity stunts
when a guy publicly calls you out to a
meeting
it's like this say there's a thousand
high school
lunch cafeteria 100 kids are there
and you tell me you know what f you
i'm like what oh okay
meet me behind the bungalows after
school okay nice 100
yeah meet me meet me behind the bunkles
after school
and i said okay 100 kids just saw me
three o'clock comes you're behind the
bungalows
i'm going home who am i the next day in
school
coward no no i'm a coward yeah putin
called
biden to go behind the bungalow
everybody went to the bungalow looking
forward to putin
to see biden there what do you think are
the chance of biden saying yes to putin
honestly zero one in what one in a
thousand
one in a million one in a billion is it
more
are you saying that just because putin
called him out he should do it
oh i i i don't think if you don't do it
you got first of all
when in the history of the diplomacy
have you seen another person saying
i want to have a live conversation with
you with the world watching when has
that ever happened
never when has that ever happened so so
one a person has the audacity to say
that because they know you're going to
say what
no i'm not they know you're going to say
no they know you're going to say no of
course they're going to say no
so now you turn it down and it's not
like it's a podcaster
saying hey biden i want you to come
forward if you nobody gives a
it's not like it's a congressman it's
not like it's a mayor of uk
it's not like it's a senator no no it's
the currently most powerful man in the
world just call you out to a duel
i got a big problem with it to be honest
with you because you've got to know what
your audience is and who you're talking
about can you imagine the level of
training
that vladimir putin putin has had as the
head of the kgb
can you imagine the negotiating skills
the the mental games that he can play
with people he's toying with biden right
now and for him that's just
it just shows a naivete that's a little
bit troubling
to me in the first couple months that
he's doing this the other thing he said
the other day that was troubling is
he referred to kamala harris as
president harris i mean he's making a
few
stumbles and bumbles here that are it
it's
it's playing into the narrative well
there's a joke there i figured you'd
segue this she is the president well no
i'm saying it's playing into a narrative
that a lot of people foresee happening
where this is segueing into you know is
he even capable of having these
discussions i think he thinks he can get
away with some of this
grandiose bravado and it's going to slip
off to the side but i mean putin just
went right at him and just toyed with
him on this
i think you know as much as i do not
think that that biden is a
classic strategist or anything like that
um
there has to be a conscious effort to
say look under trump
he was clearly cozying up to putin i
mean whether you
agree with trump or don't agree with
trump he would not call out russia
or putin whatsoever he was causing up to
dictators with kim jong-un
he was making enemies how many wars did
we have
did you go to sleep ever worrying how
many wars do we have under trump this
bad terrible human being how many wars
do we have
how was no
how many wars do we have under obama one
was the isis award in afghanistan
no that happened under bush every day
you turned on the news it was isis
you forgot like how old are you you're
40 years old what did it say
every day we saw isis how many times you
heard isis during trump
how many times you heard about people
down all you heard about is protesting
and riots
all you heard about is problems here
look don't you know if you watch my
podcast
i got a lot of trump people that can't
stand me right now because of what i've
said in the last
few comments but i'm consistent with my
views on what i believe with this
but if you if you're going to give the
argument of war
give the argument uh i didn't give the
argument a warrior you brought up war no
i'm just saying he was causing up to
dictators well that's why he was
why do you though why do you what why do
you build those relationships
so you don't have wars okay you don't
you don't make peace with your friends
in his book lincoln on leadership said
the fastest way to eliminate an enemy is
to what
turn him into a friend okay this is the
greatest president of all time there's
some genius in it maybe he read that
book maybe biden needs to read that book
maybe biden needs to go by donald t
phillips book called lincoln on
leadership
and read one of the rules of lincoln
what's sentiment copy yeah let's send
them
off at the white house okay so so all
this stuff you're saying listen i'm not
sitting here saying trump is the goat
and all this other stuff
no at all i'm not saying that i'm not
saying that at all all i'm saying is
in this area i have gone to sleep
worried about war for 10 years of my
life let's say eight years of my life
because first two years you don't even
know what it means but three years old
in iran you kind of know some shit's
going down
right when you go out there your parents
are explaining that's what happened over
there
it's not cool it's scary and that fear
didn't go away for a long time
as a kid you're always like paranoid
right when i got to the states i went to
the army
you know it went away a little bit and
then it's kind of gradually gone away
because america 911 kind of brought back
a little bit saying
this can get pretty pretty bad but
i love the fact that we have a strong
military and we are where we are
okay i love i love the fact that you
don't wake up in the morning hearing
about osama bin laden you don't hear
about isis which credit i that was an
obama thing
but you don't hear about isis that went
away under trump fully
he should have never done that what did
you hear about iran retaliating
nothing they were afraid of them now
iran doesn't even want to sit down have
a conversation with biden's people
why they would have never done that with
trump so
there are ways you have to know that a
a human being that may be the way that
he was
you were safer during that time just
telling you so
this approach here you just pissed off
the most powerful guy in the world
i'm telling you and and the worst kind
of wars you want is proxy wars and that
guy's a genius of proxy wars
genius and not only pissed him off
offended him i mean
i think the last thing you'd want to
call putin is a killer i mean literally
i mean i think that's the one word
that he would be most upset about and be
planning you know some sort of so
are we responsible this is me just
throwing this out there are we saying
that we
cannot piss off putin at all no not at
all
say some to putin or is that where
we're at right now yeah but what
we can't say about what he did bro if
you call somebody a killer diplomacy is
gone listen conor mcgregor goes and does
his
shenanigans with two mayweather
mayweather doesn't give a because
mayweather wants what
the payday he got it 300 million dollars
conor guy what a hundred million dollars
he tried to do the same thing with
khabib do you know what happened with
that fight he called out his religion
he called out his family he called us do
you know khabib wasn't fighting conor
he was defending his philosophies and
guess who was on khabib's side
a guy named putin you know what he did
to counter do you know what he did after
he beat counter
he jumped over the cage chased other
people his people got in
you don't call out certain people like
that
biden call that the person that's the
most sensitive with words like this
you have to be very careful with that oh
you think putin is sensitive about that
not sensitive sensitive in a
in a way where uh uh like you know mom
jokes in america people tell mom jokes
try to tell a mom joke to an armenian
yeah it doesn't sit within armenia i'm
actually being very serious with you
i don't like mom jokes i will never tell
mom jokes to you you mean like those yo
mama jokes
in my lifetime i've never told you your
mama joke to anybody did it the other
day here i would never say it to you
i would never say yeah you can say
you're saying there's certain lines you
can cross with certain people
you tell your mama joke to an armenian
the armenian has no clue what the hell
you're talking about
he's like what did you like i'm telling
you it's very very you say about mama
you can't say in armenia you can't tell
an army of mama jokes right now an
americanized one maybe a different story
you just cross the line with a guy like
this so we're gonna see what's gonna
happen
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you